Je me sens chanceux parce que je peux travailler
avec les meilleurs vélos afin que nous puissions faire
des choses très extrêmes, nous ne faisons pas
beaucoup de CGI, nous n'avons pas d'autres
cascadeurs qui font cela et conduisent vite sur ces
belles montagnes de l'Atlas sur des motos incroyables
nous avons des chutes de milliers de pieds totalement légitimes,
c'est tout simplement parfait pour ce qui a besoin ou
peut réellement augmenter la vitesse sérieuse cette
attitude envers le vélo,
nous les écrasons exprès et les
reconstruisons et les écrasons à nouveau, ce sont des
avions de chasse sur roues, il en a quelques
types  d'aides à la conduite que vous pouvez apporter
pour vous aider à ne pas vous écraser et
nous allons désactiver tout cela,
évidemment, comme je l'ai dit, amusons-nous un
peu avec pour le rendre moins sûr
afin que nous puissions le dériver et nous pouvons  gardez
ces vélos sur le bord
vous